welcome to your new home our new home
baby
in two seconds you will collide with
your destination
but use everyone we seem to have
survived a massive disruption in the
flow of time wait what exactly happened
here look at this
stop hiding
okay I'm done to the ship
a new virus has broken out I've
developed a test to see who's infected
ah you Sham this Q-Tip up your nose
that looks kind of fun I can't wait to
do it hundreds of times
pretty Lawless out here in crypto
country
you interested in a job
[Music]
why don't you have a belt or at least a
substantial butt sorry guys I'm a flatty
[Music]
men's gave me give that's an order
oh
[Music]
I deserve that
I'm just glad you're back
would you like to order erotic scented
massage oil or fuzzy handcuffs yes guys
that's creepy I mean yeah so creepy
[Music]
laughs